[Music]
are you guys the type to binge an entire
show in one sitting
yeah we've done it before which one I
think we've done like probably the whole
season again with those one time yeah we
did get my Thrones for 24 hours no he's
tripping you can't even do that
yeah you can't we watched Game of
Thrones for 24 hours for a video do you
know what binging means you watch like
two or three episodes know 24 hours of
Game of Thrones how is that was peer
pressuring us to catch up high so we
watched for 24 hours straight how much
did you get it only got two season yeah
just season three like the top of season
three he started from the very beginning
yes no sleeping many times at all yeah
we even did some exercises to stay awake
it was a [ __ ] yeah the first seasons
are the pace is slow food yeah it's real
slow oh it was painful
we were like a lot of dialogue yeah a
lot of knees like me oh my gosh first
season that was like young somebody got
a dive I can't keep up with we didn't
even think about turning on subtitles
it's all a while into it too so like we
couldn't understand what people are
saying like what do you say I don't
speak English what do you think they're
still on because of Game of Thrones and
luckily because we started watching
binge watching little island and they
have the same thick ass accents I don't
know if we could have understood a word
if we didn't have Simon 30% of what New
England that's like for Spanish like
Spaniard Spanish it's like I can
understand only a fraction of it because
they they have their own swings yeah oh
wow but good good yeah that's how it
feels like to be me yeah I mean I know I
can relate doubly good because I also
know bilingually quadropod fooling me
I'm smarter than you cuz I know another
language yeah and she helped a lot of
stuff yeah
magic should be a huff all that to get
to your level and she's got a little bit
about I'll go try some nos that you
should know I'm just kidding every time
you say that I think the rapper okay
that's what I thought she made I was
like yeah this whole part is just
listening to illmatic this is great guys
I love this that check I got [ __ ] up
on not don't do it kids don't do it
anyway so here in front of me I have I
have you guys heard of online gambling
calm I mean I heard about online
gambling is that the name of the website
calm it's a laundry service well they
they have crafted these two models named
Eric and Hannah to represent how our
bodies would change if we continue with
our binge watching obsession
they're like stop binge watching come
gamble what are you doing so like 20
years from now so picture these people
that they have been binge watching
Netflix for the last 20 years this is
what they would look like oh my god oh
what the [ __ ] what they like zombies
because they never spend time doing this
oh they do this all the time girl this
is still worth drawing yeah that's just
me right get a tattoo to the tattoo says
Netflix you get a chest tattoo after
binge watching a certain about you love
Netflix so much I have eaten right here
you got the tattoo artist to come to
your home
your eyes and the color of your skin
like you turn to the [ __ ] dark side
apparently it's like you're indoors for
twenty years you don't get any Sun and
like your eyes are like bloodshot
because news for there's not enough
competition looks like Darlene from
Ozark Twitter you know she's not gonna
be dead in 20 years she's a turtle yeah
that's true yeah here's she sitting on
the thing rolls the music a gamer
version they're saying like for example
here in Denton skull from pressure of
overuse of headphones and then dark
circles from sleep deprivation and
excessive screen times like something
you do as a project when you're 10 like
the teachers like draw a picture of what
would happen to you if you watch TV for
10 years straight this is your brain on
being a halter top
what does they have to do it yeah either
you can't also why is he shave every day
what's the point
you stuck your hair growth goes in back
into your body blisters fingertips lack
of sunlight and vitamin D how come one
of his hands is like that first-person
shooter excessive use of mouse and
keyboard causing numbness blisters on
fingertips from excessive use of
controller or keyboard trigger finger
which is repetitive strain injury can I
believe it though because ever since
I've been obsessed with Animal Crossing
I've stopped recently something I need
to take a break but my elbows have been
hurting and my my wrists to where I'm
like this isn't right I mean again where
you got to pay bills and stuff yeah you
got a mortgage yeah we have yeah yeah
mortgage loan what was it create your
own
it's [ __ ] cute it's really cute and
the islands really pretty and you get
this community and you have to collect
items to DIY and make your eye look
really cute that's like asking a
wisecrack fun exactly those games like
that dude it's like HD he's even a dick
it's on Nintendo right oh yeah get
that's rich but I got a switch and you
can invest in a stock market
hey you buy turnips and then throughout
the week you have to check your prices
and see if you can make a profit yeah
[ __ ] over it you guys are gonna look
like this Animal Crossing dude Bart is
like my animal crossing weight lifter
friend buck and she totally runs the
embark mine's called tank anyway part
that's so funny and then she asked me to
cuz they all have like these little
catch phrases and for him I used to I
forgot what was he like best type no but
then like I was able to change that
[Music]
tie-wearing tangent to I think I teach
it to si or whatever but it's stupid but
I don't know she's always talking about
like working out and then a1 to this
other villager she's like the sweet old
lady penguin and then he was trying to
get her to like do range aerobics so he
was trying to get her to scream and get
mad and then I was like this is so
[ __ ] Bart yeah I was buck is that
another person or that person in the
game no it's a villager yeah like in the
character or not it's not a real person
yeah but they all have personalities and
they have different personalities and
they have village drama yeah and we're
all into the village fight with each
other sometimes yeah my art Bart
character tank he got in a fight with
this other villager because the villager
was like show us your abs because he
doesn't look like very like worked out
and the end tanks like um they're not
ready yet and then the I was like I
don't think you have them if they're if
you're not showing them he's like
they're not ready I'm gonna have a party
and show everybody at the same time
that's cute they asked me like what do
you think should be show or not and I
was like yeah you just show up and he
got really pissed he was like oh and
again it's a big exclamation point and
he huffed off
abs are not already like muffin three
more months do you game it okay
yeah I mean I played FIFA Oh FIFA I play
fifa all the time I played Mario my son
I've tried for that way you had that
shirt at all no this is well my dad it's
a soccer because of my son as well I try
to wear one of these jerseys every time
I come here why cuz they'd be in the
comments like camp likes Manchester and
I'm like oh really
not really dude I really do I was
following it um before the season got
canceled bird postponed you like Madden
loved Madden I haven't played in a long
time I'm bro my sons were young they
ruined it for me
that's what I did for him she ruined it
how because he wanted to play like as he
got older I would just hand him the
other controller and it worked he's like
baby you know and then he noticed that
the Xbox thing wasn't little green yeah
so then I turned it on and then you just
get pausing in and then it just sucked
and I just stopped playing it and I just
I just that was the end of game for me
when my son realized his controller
wasn't on you do the same thing it was
that I kept beating him and I didn't
know what I was doing and he practiced
all the time and you could never beat me
I'm a Madden yeah he has the base bunch
of a bunch of idiot look like smash
whatever button I want and then she's
like hold on a second let me like trying
to figure out the controllers that's how
that's how it me and she is right she
starts out with like oh I got to figure
out the controller's just give me a
second and then she's good by the end of
the game she's crushed me like by four
touchdowns and I threw like three pics
it's all about yeah it's emasculating
dude you might as well be [ __ ]
through the trap on you switch to the
strap that's why not play that man
anymore know what it's not football
season he used to take his team and play
it against their clear:both computer
teams and he would watch it like it was
a real football game I miss football so
I avoid him
you guys I have a secret yeah but yeah I
don't what show have you guys been
binging recently other than watching
reality Rahmi I don't know if you guys
have heard of this on Hulu
it's about a muslim-american is it meal
Mila Kunis no Walsh I don't know she's
not missing it but it's super funny it
is it is great and it's a new world it's
a word that hasn't been seen on TV or
anything like that yeah so I Rami is
this Muslim dude and he lives with his
parents it's basically like how life in
Muslim community works you know like you
know they're trying to marry him off and
sister like there's double standards and
stuff about being a Muslim American in
the United States now it's fantastic oh
yeah an episode on Ramadan and stuff it
was it was great yeah my friend tell me
about it's it's it's out there though
like there's some episodes you like whoa
well maybe not you guys but people
watching might be out there well you
guys you guys can push the line Steve
strap on a couple minutes she's married
to the line yes definitely bags is odd
but it's that but then I just watch it i
watch The Office over and over and over
and I've seen it so many times my son is
on this six time I think the watching
office yes in a row since the beginning
of a quarantine he watched the office
back to back to back and he did take a a
break in the middle - Wow - watch Parks
and Rec and then also he took another
break to watch Jack Ryan
and then he went back went back into the
office your son is great I respect him
so much he's so [ __ ] funny you only
watch Jack Ryan because I couldn't get
into it you've been I can't cut to match
Jim from the office about that like does
he do all the gym like
imagine you go home and all your shits
in jello now throwing Frank no but he'll
start having like the office quotes out
of like thin air [ __ ] hilarious
that's my kids start having like some
value that's cool come little comedians
they share think that's funny and then
your cringe happens too fast and then
later they're gonna get old and we're
going to be cool again yeah yeah you're
such a beaten down dead man Oh broken
Steve that's crazy I am broken I did
everything right kids again 13 and 11
okay that's - well yeah that we enjoy
you so much here I think you're
something to think that we're cringe no
first no no you guys would be that's the
thing that hurts the most
it's just me like everybody else that
doesn't help and I do purposely bother
him like I just go in his room so it's
all your fault
what if he's facetiming or something
okay I don't go and make it oh I just
like going his room bothering what I
have clothes on yeah I understand from
the TV and hug him and stuff be a
present father I'm saying like I'm in my
son's life and I'm still paying for it
like I could have abandoned him it would
be the same thing he doesn't even
appreciate the fact that I've been here
he's like disappeared for a couple
months see how he likes it I did that on
tour no you missed me as our accent was
cold like when your next show
[Music]
you